hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host John Carroll
Stephen Hawking is known for any number
of revolutionary advances in theoretical
physics The Singularity theorems that he
did with Roger Penrose and others in the
late 60s the evaporation and radiation
from black holes in the mid 70s and in
the early 80s with Jim hartle he
calculated the wave function of the
universe to try to explain the creation
of the Universe from nothing
but in 1988 Hawking revolutionized not
theoretical physics but the scientific
publishing industry with the appearance
of A Brief History of Time his surprise
runaway bestseller I was a little bit
too young to take advantage of this but
I'm told that in the late 80s after A
Brief History of Time came out if you
were a theoretical physicist with a book
to write you could get a million dollar
advance no problem not like that anymore
but that was those were the days Andre
Linde is a well-known cosmologist whose
name will appear again in this episode
also a mischievous guy and he likes to
tell the story back in the late 80s he
would be riding an airplane sitting next
to someone who was reading A Brief
History of Time and Linde would
inevitably say you know I like the book
but I didn't really understand it and
the person reading it would go oh yeah
it's really not that hard you just have
to really concentrate while you're
reading it but Hawking never gave up
doing science you know he wrote more
books but he also wrote a lot of
technical papers in the published
research literature and his views
continued to evolve about how to do
Quantum cosmology how to think about the
nature of the quantum Universe today's
guest Thomas hertog was one of Hawking's
most frequent collaborators in those
years he was a PhD student with Hawking
and then continued to write papers with
him and has now come out with his own
book called on the origin of time
Stephen Hawking's final Theory and in
fact it it's a joint theory that he's
described in between himself and Stephen
so we'll talk about that theory but
we'll talk about the Genesis the
evolution of what we mean by Quantum
cosmology how we go about saying okay
you have the whole universe we're going
to apply the rules of quantum mechanics
to this universe and I think you will
correctly get the impression that
there's a lot that we know about how to
do that and a lot that we don't know so
our views on how best to do it are
continued evolving and it brings in both
philosophical ideas about the role of
the orig of the observer in defining
what you mean by a universe and
calculating the probability of the
universe looking different ways but also
very modern Cutting Edge physics ideas
like holography and the emergence of
time from the quantum wave function so
as I apologize to Tomas in the middle of
the podcast you know this is a tough one
for me
not because I don't understand it but
because I'm too close to the issues here
I think about these issues all the time
and so it's harder for me to put myself
in the seat of the audience member who
is not a super expert I hope that I
didn't interject my own views or
interpretations too much here I tried to
reel myself in but I don't think I was
very successful I think that you'll find
my own views all over the place so
hopefully Thomas's views uh shine
through because he he has a different
point of view that is a very interesting
message I think it's it's worth taking
very seriously especially because we
don't know the final answers we're still
working on this we're still moving
forward so let's go
[Music]
welcome to the mindscape podcast hey hi
John
you know normally and I'm sure will
happen in this episode also uh here at
the mindscape podcast we focused like a
laser beam on the substantive
intellectual content and we don't dig
that much into the personal fun stories
of of people's histories and so forth
but in your case uh you were Stephen
Hawking's most frequent collaborator in
the last years of his life and that
collaboration forms a lot of the basis
of what you're going to tell us about in
the podcast and in the book that you've
written uh how does one become Stephen
Hawking's collaborator I'm sure there's
a story there yeah but it's it's it's
it's a typical science story right
um
there was a folklore there was there was
sort of a lore at uh a well-known sort
of story at the department of Appliance
mathematics and theoretical physics in
Cambridge which was uh whoever got top
scores uh in their famous part three
course would get an invitation to go
talk to Stephen and so that's
essentially what happened then what
happened to many other students in
different years
um so that's how I first entered into
his office uh the real surprise of
course was the experience of that first
conversation which was anything but
normal
um
it was not normal because it was
interspersed with various uh journalists
walking in and out and the second thing
which I thought was very exceptional was
that Stephen went just straight in and
started talking about
how we found that whole idea of the
Multiverse so paradoxical and how his
colleague Andre Linde at these
outrageous theories and so there there I
was how could I possibly have an opinion
of the Multiverse and Andre Linde
has a 22 year old student but that was
that was really fun and you know again
we're not going to spend most of time
talking about this stuff but how did it
work your collaboration I mean again
later in life Steven had a tougher and
tougher time uh banging out the
sentences right right right right right
yes yes I think I was I was lucky in a
sense
for two reasons
um the timing late 90s this was Stephen
and I met 98 really
um yeah I think it was really a
coincidence why it worked so well
first of all on your point in terms of
communication
so Stephen was already using his
computer voice at the time but the whole
system worked really well right he had
this sort of uh he he was used to using
a mouse to select words and and and and
he sort of my impression was that by
then he sort of instinctively knew when
we click to select certain words and so
the whole system was working very well
in the late 90s so of course I had a
notion of time
and so we would sit hours and hours in
that department shoulder to shoulder and
he would type out sentence and sentence
and by by okay if you spend so much time
by at some point you you begin to
understand what he's talking about and
and you get going
so that was that was important because
those years really were a foundation for
when it became very difficult later on
to communicate I think at that point
these first few years we developed some
sort of intuition good uh common
language the second point I think which
was equally relevant is that the late
90s were a great time in cosmology hmm
um Steven's famous book A Brief History
of Time had been out for like a decade
um so the frenzy around that book had
sort of died down he was back to
research and he was back to research
because
cosmology was was what was it was a
golden era right uh you had these
mystifying observations about the
acceleration of the universe the CMB
fluctuations which were pointing to an
early phase of acceleration which we now
call inflation
uh and then you had these paradoxes to
do with the Multiverse which were
essentially going
to the core of cosmological theory
so this was a good time Stephen was
Stephen was grounded in research again
um and still being able to communicate
and that's what we built on I would say
and in particular the research that you
did together
um I think it's fair to say always as
always correct me if I'm wrong here uh
is sort of Downstream from the wave
function of the universe work that he
did with Jim hartle in the early 1980s
so Quantum cosmology in some sense so
why don't you explain to us what that is
what's about that what is the wave
function of the universe Thomas
hey
okay good
um
well so
innovate a whole wave function
thinking the whole sort of idea of let's
think about the universe in a quantum
mechanical way as a Quantum system
must have been sort of moral lesson that
Stephen took out of his PhD work his own
PhD work in the 1960s when he
essentially showed using penrose's
techniques that the Big Bang
uh
uh classically the origin of the
universe the Big Bang in Einstein's
theory is a singularity where where
Einstein's theory breaks down it's the
origin of time
uh is this gonna be an unjust theory if
you would take it at face value
you'd almost be driven to the statement
okay this is not sign this this lies
outside signs but of course there's
another lesson the one the one Stephen
and most of our colleagues look well
wait a minute they just Quantum the
quantum nature of gravity becomes
important but then how do you go about
doing something about that that's when
that's I think when when Jim and Steve
and pioneering work came about well if
the universe is a quantum system that it
must have a Quantum State somehow a very
abstract super abstract description of
reality
um and the Ingenuity of of stevensburg
which which featured so much in a brief
history of Thailand
was that he came up with the first
fairly explicit model of how you would
go about giving a Quantum description of
the Big Bang of the creation of the
universe and their trick was really to
sort of in a way
bent the time dimension of Einstein's
theory into a space Dimension and if
your reality is pure space dimensions
you know what to do to close it you can
just round it off like a sphere and so
Steven's famous line of course was what
is the big bang it's a bit like the
South Pole and what was there before
well it's like asking what's out of the
South Pole it's a meaningless question
so that was of course the typical
oracular uh
phrase right
but by the late 90s Stephen and many
others had realized that the creation
Theory so to speak of Brief History of
Time had a fundamental problem which is
that taken at face value
you'll be led to the conclusion that the
Universe should be empty that the
Universe should be yeah that there
should be no stars no galaxies no life
and so while
their original Theory
was beautiful in a way from a
theoretical perspective it's almost like
you and I think he's I think he felt
like that that he that he sort of had
cracked the Enigma of creation so to
speak by by giving a mathematical
description of how you can make a
universe
it was very much
um
it was not the kind of universe we
inhabit so there was something missing
right I actually I do that's going to be
a heart and soul I think of this
conversation because it's a it's really
that what your book builds up to but I
want to linger in the 80s for a little
while uh to get the set up so that
everyone comes in on the same page here
so when we say the quantum state of a
system if it's an electron or something
like that something that we are very
used to treating as a quantum mechanical
object it's a wave function for every
position that we could measure it in it
tells us the probability Etc so it's a
it's a function of every possible
location we could measure it what do you
mean when you say the wave function of
the universe is it is it supposed to be
it sounds hard to write down a possible
Quantum amplitude for every particle in
the universe right and it is worse than
that
if you treat if I mean what we really
mean and certainly what Stephen meant in
the 80s by a wave function of the
universe
is very much a wave function not just of
the of a particle describing various
positions of a particle like an electron
but really a sort of abstract
description that describes a
superposition of various possible
universes including all the matter and
the space and time so it's almost like
you go from one Universe to
a zoo of possible universes and so you
really go up a level in abstraction and
a level and in confusion right yeah and
frankly I think the question what we
mean by a refunction May well be at the
heart of of of these these these more
recent developments with Stephen and and
and and what what we worked on yeah good
because of course with the wave function
predicts an empty Universe if the empty
universe is the by far the dominant wave
Crest so to speak
yeah then you know something's missing
right there yeah good but this was this
was Linda's complaint right uh Stephen
would be saying yeah with your
Multiverse you have infinitely many
observers and you don't know where we
are and then Linda would say by your
wave function has no observers that
that's equally bad maybe maybe that is
even worse honestly yes yes I can I
didn't want to say it but okay I mean I
want to give the listeners a feeling for
how we uh operationally go about this I
mean clearly you're gonna have to make
some simplifications if you're going to
think about the wave function of the
universe yes yes one what is what what
is the what is the what is the goal here
it is really just like we do in ordinary
physics problems we try thought
experiments we try to simplify the
situation but of course in such a way
that you think or that you hope to
capture the essence of the problem
and
um
I'm my impression is that that this has
worked pretty well in in this Quantum
cosmology program of course it is not an
exact it is not an exact way function it
is not a precise formulation
but somehow and a little bit a little
bit miraculously
um the the general framework of quantum
cosmology it seems to me has has been
able to capture a few
key foundational features of how we go
about cooking
about the quantum Universe
um which have been very difficult to
discover by other means
it obviously runs into the question that
you know the person on the street has
been told every day of their life that
we don't understand quantum gravity
so it sounds like you're doing quantum
gravity even though we don't understand
it how do you get away with that yeah so
somehow we get away with that
um
I think we understand
some some I think we understand more
than we sometimes admit good I don't
think we understand we have learned a
lot about sort of the the conceptual
framework maybe we don't have a precise
mathematical picture but and you can see
where this is where this goes right
um these these these toy models do
capture certain essential features the
universe the fact that the Universe
inflates at Early Times
uh and also
yeah this this idea that well as we all
know from quantum mechanics the act of
observation plays a crucial role right
an electron doesn't really have a
position as long as we don't ask for it
but that is a fundamental different
thing from a classical system which of
course has a position and a momentum so
imagine now thinking about the universe
as a wave function
as a description of all possible
universes maybe it isn't quite real
until we bring in the Observer and so
that has been a role fruitful area I
think to to study the kind of questions
to study ultimately the relation between
our existence and and the nature of the
universe in in a quantum mechanical
setting something which classically you
cannot begin to ask really yeah so
I'm a bit more optimistic we keep saying
we don't understand quantum gravity but
I think we are there's one way along
um
and and that's then and then we haven't
even talked about holography right we we
will don't you worry but I do want one
more I do want to uh yeah again give a
flavor of some of the uh some of the
issues that one faces here you already
mentioned uh
turning time into something that looks
like space I mean this was infamously
the part in A Brief History of Time
where most people are like okay I give
up because he started talking about
imaginary time yeah so uh you you're
welcome to say no but could you explain
what imaginary time is and why it
mattered why you had to do that like
time is real to you and me why do you
have to make it imaginary ah well but
yeah okay time time is real to you and
me here and that's so that's all fine
but as we discussed already when we go
back in the history of the universe to
her the earliest stages the einsteinian
way of thinking about the expanding
Universe we run it backwards and and and
and time time stops so
you could already have said in the 60s
or even earlier in fact because the this
this idea that time had an origin and
that that was the Big Bang who has been
around for 90 years
so the discovery of the Big Bang to me
the fact that the Big Bang is the origin
of time already shows that there must be
something emergent about time if you're
gonna understand the Big Bang we better
don't put in time as a prior assumption
because it's all about
how the
Dimension or perception of time as we
know it and as we experience it comes
about so I would say that the dimension
of time has been a problem all along in
modern relativistic cosmology and in
that sense
um Stephen strick to sort of turn time
into space
is in a way exactly what the doctor
ordered
it's a bit radical but then the Big Bang
is a very radical phenomenon right
um yeah and in fact that was later much
later we shouldn't probably go too deep
into this but now uh
uh almost 40 years on really from
Steven's time into time goes into space
business now we understand that this is
much disease yeah now we understand how
that trick so to speak is much less uh
random as as it looks but in fact
emerges from uh our new holographic way
of thinking about the universe much more
as an effective description so
of course this was Stevens this saw
Steven's bold sort of characteristic way
of doing physics back back in the days
um he had an intuition that he could do
all of physics without time essentially
um everything could be just spatial
euclidean geometries and
I must say that since he died that kind
of physics that kind of approach to
quantum gravity both in terms of black
holes and and in terms of the Big Bang
has has gained regained importancy right
we did have a podcast episode with Neda
engelhardt uh who was one of the people
working on
getting information out of black holes
and the idea of euclidean quantum
wormholes loomed large yeah and so hoki
would have liked that I think that's
right okay good but I'm still I'm still
stuck in the 80s because you know look
I'm older than you my formative years
were uh back in the 80s and the big
thing at that time you already mentioned
Andre Linde and and Hawking had a little
bit of a disagreement about the wave
function of the universe it grew into
this disagreement about the Multiverse
Etc but but back in the day it was just
about inflation and can we get inflation
out of our theory of quantum cosmology
so right why don't you explain to the
listeners what inflation is and why it
matters to us okay yeah
um so inflation indeed came
along in the early 80s
um somewhat independent I think of
Steven's Quantum creation mobile
um
as a way of more of inflation what is
inflation inflation is a very rapid
phase of inflam in in expansion in the
earliest stages of the universe this
Evolution which creates a big universe
in a fraction of a sec and so it sort of
interconnects our entire observable
universe
and to me the the big bonus of inflation
is that because it's such a rapid phase
of expansion it kind of it it sort of
um generates with it a pattern of
fluctuations a pattern of variations in
the universe
um purely Quantum uncertainty
essentially their particles that are
being sort of uh teared out of the
vacuum and set you up with a big
universe that is not exactly the same
everywhere it comes with some sort of
roughness and that roughness is exactly
what you need to uh over millions and
millions of years generated stars and
galaxies and so forth so inflation on
its own
and that's I mean it has been I would
say there's significant observation
support for such an early phase of Rapid
expansion because the roughness that you
generate during inflation is reflected
in the famous uh Cosmic microwave
background images which uh show that the
temperature wasn't equally distributed
but nearly equally distributed right
um so inflation stands on its own really
but the big question of course which
must have been the question I think in
the early 80s but okay how does it how
does inflation start and that's where
all the disagreements came wrong yeah I
mean I think that I think amazingly that
was not a question that most
inflationary cosmologists cared about I
mean they just said well as long as it
starts it gets us what we want but but
Hawking and Linde and a few others like
Alex for Lincoln were you know a Plucky
minority who really tried to understand
why it would start and that was part of
what the wave function the universe was
supposed to be about right okay okay but
of course also since then I think we've
learned that uh
it is an important question how
inflation started yeah because uh
the pattern of variations didn't say the
cosmic microwave background radiation
that the Afterglow of the Big Bang uh is
gonna depend on precisely how inflation
unfolded so it's not that it's it's not
an empty question I mean the specific
mechanism that drives inflation in the
early Universe leaves its observational
traces so if we want to predict the
details the fine details of of of those
fossils so to speak we better understand
how it starts yeah I agree with you but
you know again Plucky minority I think
you're right that it's more common these
days and but there is you know a slight
maybe I don't want to say downside but
implication of this that you already
mentioned which is that there are these
Quantum fluctuations that mean that
inflation is a little bit rough it
doesn't end the same everywhere and on
very large scales those fluctuations can
be very big and give rise to a
Multiverse and you know different things
going on in different places and someone
like Andre Linde embraced that
Multiverse and and said okay there it is
that explains why our own universe is so
unusual looking because it's a tiny tiny
part of some gigantic Ensemble my
impression is that Stephen uh and you
did not Embrace that picture quite as
lovingly that is correct
[Laughter]
yes yes and
right right I think this is this is
exactly the moment where I where I
entered Steven's office so at the heart
of that disagreement
um somehow I think Andre so the the
problem of it's appealing in one sense
the Multiverse because they suppose you
will need to generate a huge expanding
space
where different regions
um behave like different universes even
with different effective laws of physics
yeah then you generate some sort of
gigantic reality in which the apparent
biophilic design of our universe would
be just a natural fluke and that's it
yeah so it I think it appeals to to some
cosmologists that this would get us
around a lot of the
perceived fine-tuning
um issues the idea for the the
observation uh that our universe is at a
level of physics remarkably Fit for Life
uh of course if there are a zillion
universes out there then once in a while
you're gonna have such a such a universe
but there was one problem from from and
which was which was clear in the 90s
already which is okay suppose you have a
Multiverse then if you want to turn this
into a fully uh a full-fledged
scientific hypothesis
you better tell me in which of these
universes we should be and therefore
what we should observe what kind of
roughness in the CMB we should observe
or what kind of value for this or that
parameter we should expect to observe
and so that's that's something in
between each cosmologists
um
called The Measure issue at the measure
problem and the measure problem is
really how should we in a gigantic
Multiverse
um associate what weight should we
associate to different kinds of
universes how important are different
kind of universes in this gigantic
reality and so I think that was the
crucial Point somehow I think
Stephen thoughts to that to to to get a
proper scientific falsifiable hypothesis
out of the Multiverse would would
require a radical Quantum thinking
whereas I think other people like Linda
Todo had a measure issue it's eventually
it's gonna go away
uh
um by some sort of entropic principle or
by another beats
um and that's of course a very
interesting debate because uh this goes
to the heart of what cosmological theory
is about yeah
how do we fit into the grand scheme are
we is there a giant inflating space in
which the anthropic principle is going
to select our universe
or is this giant inflating space not
quite there without
bringing in that observer's perspective
in a more fundamental the way interwoven
with physical Theory itself with Quantum
with Quantum thinking and you're going
to be on the latter half
you bet
well let's let's linger lovingly over
this distinction because I think it's an
important one but it's also a difficult
one uh
cosmologists who do think about the
universe or for that matter people who
do black hole information or whatever
anyone who talks about quantum gravity
it seems to me
is very tempted by still drawing a
classical picture of space-time even
though they know they're talking about
quantum gravity and saying well there
are fluctuations of some sort but I I
take it the point you're making it seems
from reading the book I I cheated by
reading the book
um that's not really fair to a truly
Quantum Universe isn't just a big
fluctuating classical universe is that
fair
right I think that is indeed the key
distinction that you either assume that
there is some sort of background out
there
which can be widely fluctuating in
different regions
but the sort of big big background in
which all these happenings in which all
this is happening acts as yeah some sort
of foundation various but this took many
years ever now now I'm jumping around I
mean Stephen in the late 90s didn't have
this didn't have the solution
um but eventually as you as you suggest
we came to see that this is still too
classical this is still too much of
um yeah it's not enough Quantum I can't
say it differently
and so we start to try to go try to try
to try to take a fully quantity view
even though we of course didn't have a
precise Theory to do so and you're led
to a different picture in which we have
rather
um a classical space around us of course
which can be much bigger than the
observable universe but which sort of
dissolves in uncertainty on the largest
scale so it's much like what we were
saying earlier about the electron the
electron doesn't have quite a position
in quantum theory before we ask for its
position so if we think in the same way
about the universe globally we should be
saying that the universe is a definite
space time and configuration around us
but on the larger scales it it's rather
uncertainty which dominates instead of a
definite classical structure extending
dual Infinity as some as some people
would say so it's a it's a picture I
which I came to see that builds in a
certain finitude so quantum theory is
interesting in that respect it has
always been interesting in that respect
in the sense that it's a theory of what
we can know but also a theory that sort
of tells us would become no and here
um in our in our model this is sort of
playing out yeah at a lot at the level
of the larger scales by the way this
will be of interest to our listeners are
you
assuming in the background something
like the many worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics I'm certainly assuming
an interpretation
um that is like many worlds in the sense
that I'm trying to work with an
interpretation of quantum theory that
doesn't require anything external yeah
right or any hidden variables for that
matter yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
definitely cosmology Adobe we often
think about quantum mechanics and and
the many world interpretation when we
think about uh future branches also we
make we prepare an experiment the wave
function splits The Observer gets
correlated with one outcome and so forth
but the thing which I found striking in
cosmology is that the current state of
the universe around us is already the
result of a giant question asked of the
wave function and so it's sort of the
the many world interpretational in
cosmology also acts a lot or I think is
important when it comes to the Past sure
in selecting this or that subset of of
histories
and like editing like any branching in
in in in in in in
Quantum cosmology say
it comes with limitations so in a in a
sense you could say the Multiverse it's
it's almost we're behaving as if we have
access to an infinite amount of
information whereas of course from an
observer's perspective within the
universe there's a the extent to which
our observations distill one or another
branch of the wave function is is finite
and and Stephen's tricky tool to close
the universe to turn time into space
helps in that respect I think this would
be a great opportunity to clarify
something about you know again the
person on the street who's not playing
with equations here's words and and
tries their best to figure out what's
going on so we hear about Feynman and
his sum over histories right like
Feynman said consider all possible
histories of the particle or the
universe and there's a certain way of
adding them adding their contributions
together to get the quantum wave
function and and Stephen and Jim hartle
used that idea intimately when they
wrote down their wave function that's
different than Everett's view of many
branches of the wave function because
his individual branches are supposed to
be real they're not mathematical
fictions that we add up and in some
sense they're kind of classical right so
is that a fair distinction the way
you're thinking about it yes I think so
um so I think it's more the Feynman kind
of description that is perhaps at the
heart of this Theory
um well let's let's get down to brass
tacks do you believe that there really
exist other universes where things are
very different other branches that does
not quite enter in our Theory okay
um
and that is because in the end
as certainly certainly inspired by these
holographic uh constructions they work
very much what we call top down so
backwards in time so they're very much
anchored so to speak the histories that
play a role in the wave function or
anchors on
yeah I would say our observational
situation around us and so in a sense I
my feeling is that the the new
holographic wave flooding cosmology is
going to at the very least trim the wave
function of the universe down to
yeah I would say a more manageable thing
okay but if I observe a spin that's in a
superposition of spin up and spin down
and yeah I see that it's spin up do you
think there's another version of me that
saw spin down or as an operational
meaning sure
you say sure a lot of people think
that's a radical thought to think that
there's a a version of me that's all
spin down sure but that branching Once
You observe it sure so I would I would
view that as an operational way of
describing uh your setup okay your
experiment your observation but once
once the observation has unfolded what
happens to the other U
it's lost in uncertain again I would say
and every branch that that that that
that grows out of the other you uh will
no longer be uh contributing to this
universe okay so let me try out the
following analogy that struck me as I
was thinking about your podcast so if we
if we do
let's say we do Schrodinger's cat right
so Schrodinger puts the cat in a Quantum
superposition of alive and dead and
famously if we open the box and look at
the cat we don't see the quantum
superposition we see the cat alive or
the cat dead I think that what you're
saying is kind of like the following
that if I had an infinite series of cats
spread out in space I could look at one
of them and it would either be alive or
dead but very very far away the cats
could still be in a superposition and it
would be a mistake for me to think of
this Ensemble as just a random
collection of cats alive and dead it
becomes more and more Quantum as you go
further away uncertain indeed yeah just
like the electron position yeah
and so yeah
we should think of cosmology like that
we can talk about the classical world
that we see but let's not extend this
classical picture too far away let's
leave it uncertain that seems to me to
be the lesson
and that's also at a heart of how this
Quantum way of thinking about it
resolves the measure problem because it
is anchored on Over Georgia said what we
see rather than try together to get us
into the to the picture into the cosmos
A posteriori so to speak yeah like for
instance uh
someone with an anthropic principle
would do and is this the what do you
mean by the top-down approach yes so say
I say pretend that we didn't just say
that tell us what the top-down approach
is
please right right so
what we mean by a top-down approach is
indeed that we regard the universe as we
observe it around us
um
as a kind of starting point for which of
the many possible histories of the
universe contribute to to what we see
and what we observe and that is
important because it provides you
selecting those selecting those
histories or selecting those subset of
branches in the wave function then
allows you to make predictions for
future observations because that's kind
of the problem with the Multiverse right
if you have many different universes and
you want to predict something for a
future observation for the next
satellite yeah you need some sort of
criteria and that's that's good that was
very much at a sort of that was sort of
the guideline also for Stephen and me so
to get to get we sort of had this
intuition that a proper Quantum way of
thinking about the universe should
somehow resolve this sort of give us a
measure and give us give us an
unambiguous Criterion for
future predictions but it comes with a
radical different perspective of course
because we used to be able we used to
think that we would one day be able to
predict from first principles How the
Universe should be How the Universe
should turn out
um that was the kind of attitude that
Hawking took in in Brief History of Time
like a sort of transcendental theory
that tells us why and how the universe
is the way it is that's how he phrased
it
and
he totally came he totally turned turned
180 degrees on this point which which I
think well what was a very interesting
um a very interesting Evolution to to
witness in his thinking so I want to
make sure that the listeners know what
we mean we say the measure problem
um in a Multiverse in a very big
Multiverse that we do as as you and I
agree it would be sloppy and careless to
think of it as a big classical Ensemble
of things but let's think of it that way
anyway there's a lot of observers they
see a lot of different things uh you
know different cosmological constants
different masses of the electron or
whatever and a a traditional
Multiverse cosmology thing to do would
be to say what is the chance that you
observe the electron Mass to be a
certain number and the problem is
there's an infinite number of observers
in this universe who observe it to be a
certain number and also an infinite
number that observe it to be a different
number and it's very hard to take
Infinity divided by Infinity to figure
out what fraction of people will see a
certain thing that's the measure problem
in my mind yeah
yeah I think it's one version uh
there's a different aspect which I think
is closely related to what you say
so you we are we asked the question
faced with the Multiverse we would ask
the question what's the probability that
b c this or that yeah but there is this
subtlety in what we mean by b yes uh
depending if you have a different
definition or a different description of
what the V means what physical
characteristics you associate to an
observer be it a human Observer uh or or
a habitable planet or just a Galaxy
depending on how you chose
to Define that you're going to get a
different answer
yeah and so there is it's almost not
settable settable uh by rational
arguments because you could turn all you
could turn a negative outcome into a
positive outcome by changing what you
mean by we
and so that's another version of I think
the measure problem a version which
points very clearly
to the underlying problem with the
Multiverse that it is a construction a
kind of platonic construction that is
out there
independently of whether it is observed
or not it's out there with an
independent existence from us
and that frankly it took many years uh
um by the time I sort of fully realized
that
the depth of the problem the gods I view
in other words yeah it's what Stephen
Gold's gold indeed and many others I
think yeah the gods the God's eye view
um which and indeed then bye bye 2005 or
so we were absolutely convinced that uh
we had to yeah
um
construct cosmology in a different way
from what's what Stephen called a warm's
eye view not a very good termite it's
okay you get the idea right
well I I do think I actually really like
the philosophy behind it I think it's
kind of a shame that Stephen famously
you know went to rhetorical war against
the philosophers because I think that
there's useful Harmony I agree yeah no
that's a good point
um and one can wonder why that was to
sell books
you think so I you know he uh more than
I do well I I I I I can say that people
who knew about you know how he
constructed his famous sentences about
philosophy being dead and so forth in uh
The Grand Design it was very clearly to
sell books oh but
um right that is probably true but my
feeling is uh but I'm not sure I'm not a
biographer right but my feeling is that
the whole philosophy is that thing of
how King predates The Grand Design
he he was never a fan of philosophy no
that's true but that doesn't distinguish
him from plenty of other physicists
right like plenty of physicists uh well
right but wrongly so I think if you now
look back on or just on the conversation
we had
this issue Gold's eye versus let's call
it worm's eye is is foundational yes
because it is really about what is It
ultimately that physical Theory Theory
finds out about the world is it some
sort of Eternal transcendental truth or
is physical Theory once you get the
Observer fully Incorporated in there
um a different beast from what we
thought it was contingent on our
existence within the universe right and
that's uh for this I mean I we I think
we must admire Stephen for the for just
for the simple fact that he was able to
change his mind on this oh yeah sure
um so in at the end towards the end of
my life of his life he he said literally
by okay with top down with that new
approach to cosmology somehow we put
humankind back in the center that is a
very different Stephen from the one we
could read in A Brief History of Time
very much and I will I do I should
apologize to you because all of what you
do and talk about in the book is too
close to things that I care about so
instead of asking you questions I keep
saying what about this but I hopefully
you can deal with my question asking
style so so let me do it again let me
let me say what about this because I I
think that this this question of
predicting what we should be like if
this certain Multiverse uh were true is
exactly wrong-headed that that's the
point on which I completely agree with
you like what do you mean what we should
be like we're us you know where we are
what we are like uh I do think it's
possible and you could probably say this
even classically in a big fluctuating
Ensemble you could ask what is the
probability that your theory predicts
the existence of anybody like you and if
that probability is is one who cares if
there's many more people not like you
you're going to be there in in the
Multiverse right or in in the in the
theory that's right that's right yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah certain
probabilities we just don't care about
and Jim hartle and Mark shouldnicki made
a made a point about this with the
example of jovians do you know their
example about the jovians sure yeah can
you tell it to us to the readers to the
listeners oh I don't remember the
details but uh they they
you can correct me but their point was
that
um
it should be expect
um in some giant Ensemble of
uh inhabitancy should we expect to be
typical yeah in in one or another sense
um given that all we know is that we
exist yeah and so they made a big point
in explaining that the mere observation
of the fact that we exist is very very
different if you don't have access to
other civilizations or planets or
extraterrestrials from saying that we
should be typical right and the reason
is ones and is is the say is the same as
what we were discussing earlier
typicality
in the end always boils down to uh
treating certain features of our living
systems or biosphere or planet or Galaxy
as preferred as
the most probable and and and but that
is that is that is that is
fallacious thinking really
so good so I I think that uh we're very
much on the same wavelength there you
know I I take it you would agree that
there's no reason to think that you or I
as individuals or human beings as a
species are typical in the universe and
even and this is the key point and even
that nature of the physical laws that we
observe is the typical outcome of some
Grand uh Cosmic Evolution exactly good
so all right so the neither is the
neither is the tree of life on Earth
as sketched first by Darwin the typical
outcome of that evolution
in a sense Stephen and I pushed that
same kind of thinking further down and
we're saying well wait a minute maybe
the physical laws as we have them are
also not a typical outcome but and this
is the crucial point just like Darwin
just like Darwin didn't need a zillion
other planets to do biological evolution
on this planet
we claim we don't need a zillion other
universes to study the evolution of this
universe but it comes crucially as you
point out it comes crucially with the
caveat that there is no Assumption of
typicality
and there is no it could have turned out
differently yeah that's that and to me
the big surprise and this is really when
when the moment that Stephen sort of
told me look now it's time for a new
book
the real surprise this is as a matter of
giving some homework right yeah
um was that Hollow that holographic way
of thinking
about cosmology
builds in much of that top-down
reasoning because the holography
in a cosmological context
really flows backwards in time
from data from an observational
situation in the present the time the
past the time Dimension is in a sense
the emergent Dimension and it's
contingent on
the kind of questions you ask and that
for me was sort of the key transition
point because previously
much of that top-down reasoning we were
preaching so to speak
remained controversial because it felt
like a choice it fell to so many people
like David Gross who tell who tell us ah
but wait a minute you're putting in the
answer
so that's this typicality reasoning
again right you're putting in the answer
I'm trying to explain I'm trying to
predict the answer and and uh you kind
of feel like maybe maybe he's right and
you know like he has a Nobel Prize and
all that you see
um but then holography sort of
solidified the top-down reasoning
precisely because it flows backward it
works
um backwards in time
and
I was very surprised by that and I think
Stephen Stephen was too and um so okay
that that's when it all sort of began to
click together our picture well if you
want us to believe that which is a good
thing to do you're gonna have to tell us
more about holography and how it goes
backward in times I don't know where you
want to start but what what do you mean
when you're saying holography in this
context
um okay so we want to talk a bit about
logger yeah you wrote a book
it's your job
um so holography has been let's face it
holography has been the Talk of the Town
in theoretical physics for 25 years
right yeah but of course it's true it's
been mostly practiced in highly
idealized abstract non-realistic uh
mathematical situations universes that
have nothing to do with ours but there's
a general lesson behind holography which
is I think it's been
the way which we're finding out in which
quantum theory and gravity can finally
work together more or less harmoniously
and
the way this works is that
um
one appears to be the Hologram of the
other the
the
clearest example perhaps is is the case
of a black hole why don't we think about
the black hole we've seen images of a
black hole uh that's all very nice and a
black hole is something very
gravitational right the the space time
is curved highly curved Einstein says
there is a there is a Surface there is a
horizon
uh an inside Horizon inside the black
hole space-time really crumbles
um so that's the gravitational
description of a black hole but then
when you start thinking about a black
hole from a Quantum perspective you
begin to discover going back to the work
of beckenstein and how King and many
others that well maybe all there is to
know about the black hole is in fact uh
located in bits of information
that are living in on the horizon
surface that are living on the surface
so if you start reasoning about a black
hole that way
you might arrive at the conclusion that
the inside of the black hole
doesn't really exist or isn't or is in a
sense
yeah not quite there isn't it some sort
of emergent emergent
phenomenon which you may not need if you
want to ask physical questions you could
ask physical questions from a Quantum
perspective and just only talk about the
horizon or a little taken to rise so I
think that's much of the more motivation
or inspiration for maybe there is a a
fully Quantum way of thinking about the
universe about space and time is in a
sense holographic in the sense that
there is one dimension in the case of a
black hole the interior Dimension that
is emergent that is not quite phenomenal
and now you begin to think about wait a
minute wait a minute uh the Big Bang is
another problematic thing uh just like
black holes space-time crumbles
um what dimension in cosmology could be
the one that is holographically
projected that is sort of encoded in a
lower dimensional screen like thing
uh just like a hologram
well as we discussed in cosmology it is
very much the dimension of time which is
the problematic one it's the one that
has an origin it's the one that
disappears with the big bang it's the
one that causes us a headache
and the development of those holographic
ideas in theoretical physics indeed
suggests that it is the dimension of
time in a cosmological context that can
be holographically encoded in
a hologram
so we start with a moment of time or you
know some some some spatial description
of the universe and then we kind of do
holographic tricks to understand how
that could be projected into time
Evolution I'm just stringing words
together like chat GPT here you can you
can fix that
uh right right the way I see it is that
there is okay I I want to say two things
here first of all this holographic way
of thinking about reality is completely
useless in normal circumstances right
today here around you around me around
everywhere there is time and there is
space and and we can work with that yeah
but where holography becomes important I
think
is where Einstein's theory either where
the description of reality in terms of
space and time that we experienced where
that description doesn't hold so inside
black holes and at the Big Bang
my feeling is that in those extreme
regions of the universe the more
fundamental holographic Quantum nature
Rises to the Forefront
so what I mean by that is that in those
extreme regions of the universe one of
the familiar demand Dimensions
disappears so in the case of the black
hole it's the interior of the black hole
in the case of the universe if we go if
we trace the history of the universe
backwards it's all fine but at some
point the bending of time becomes so
strong
and you think what holography is telling
us is that rarely effect the dimension
doesn't reach further the holographic
way of saying the same thing would be
that the hologram
doesn't quite unquote the information
to push history further backwards and so
the Big Bang in holographic way of
thinking about the universe becomes
almost like it becomes almost like an
epistemic horizon a really a region
where you called yeah you run out of
bits almost literally
that's kind of uh where it stands of
course it has to be this is a grand new
hypothesis
so many ways to sort of get a gist right
yeah no I do and so maybe a model might
be classically we would say if we kept
going backward in the history of the
universe time would end because we hit
the Big Bang Singularity and what you're
saying is time kind of ceases to be a
thing it's not that it ends but it
ceases to be a useful way of talking
about the universe yeah I think indeed
um
right right gradually
in a way what we have been trying to do
in in cosmology ever since the discovery
of the Big Bang is to let time when we
go backwards disappear in a controlled
fashion sure and that's essentially that
has essentially been the goal
um and of course it's kind of
interesting to look back on this because
this is what the singularity theorems in
the 60s tell us to do find a better way
to find find a better way to to let time
disappear into the Big Bang so that
physics doesn't break down
and of course these ideas about the
Multiverse or about pre-bigbang
cosmologies their sort of ideas that all
go in the direction well maybe the Big
Bang wasn't really the origin maybe
there's something maybe we can just push
through yeah do physics as we as we
normally do it but it's kind of
interesting that this hypothesis that I
developed with Hawking is very different
it's taking the idea of An Origin
very seriously in fact even more
seriously than than the early Hawking
you would would have done it in the
sense that if you let the time Dimension
disappear
it's it's as if the laws of physics
and so
it's it's really sort of placing that
notion of An Origin very Central in our
thinking about the early universe and in
that sense I think we can now begin to
see clearer the difference between this
hypothesis and and other hypothesis is
that that that
evoke uh
an evolution before the Big Bang and all
that well let me
consider two different cosmological
scenarios one is one much like we think
is real in other words we have observers
like us today and we Trace back 14
billion years and there was a big bang
and that big bang by the way was a very
low entropy special condition as Roger
Penrose and others have have pointed out
another one might be there's sort of a
galaxy kind of like the Milky Way in
people like us but the whole background
space time is otherwise empty
so there's no big bang there's just a
weird random fluctuation in which all
the particles came together to make the
our galaxy and then they'll disperse in
the future and then there's no beginning
to end of time
does your theory explain
why our universe looks like the former
rather than the latter
right I'm writing a paper on that good
hurry up
what are you doing being on podcasts
when you should be writing your paper
Thomas
okay
um
my claim is the following that if you
specify insufficient detail
the local
Galactic uh configuration that you
sketched by Me by by which I mean really
the actual configuration so you specify
enough data yeah then you will see a
switch I'm revealing really the latest
research here you'll feel we feel a
switch in from uh from your second
scenario to your first scenario so if
you only sort of loosely say well I've
got some sort of Milky Way I'm not very
much interested in its precise
description then you might as well favor
an empty Universe without anything else
but if you begin to describe that
observation situation the fact that uh
act in any insufficient detail
then at some point it'll become uh
uh you will see a phase transition you
will see a shift towards the universe
like we actually observe it okay I will
go on the record as saying that would be
great and I don't believe you but we can
talk about that you should be skeptical
I am skeptical I think that is even I
could I could I would claim that you can
specify to whatever level of detail you
want uh the the world around us to uh
you know a hundred thousand parsecs in
every direction surrounded by vacuum and
everything is perfectly fine okay uh
wait and what is what is the statement
that the statement is that it doesn't
matter how carefully I specified my
current observations here in the big
bang I can always embed them in a
universe sorry here in the Milky Way my
sorry my mistake I can always embed them
very easily in the universe without a
big bang at all and I I suspect strongly
and though I don't know maybe I'm wrong
about this maybe this is what you can
convince me of but I suspect strongly
that in in most known principled ways of
comparing the likelihood of those two
possibilities the the empty universe is
going to come out more likely yeah yeah
so indeed uh what I'm going to reveal uh
is indeed of course a different way to
compare these likings good I look
forward to seeing that but okay
um I guess the last loose end here this
been has been excellent thank you very
much for explaining a lot of this modern
research to us I just want to get
straight one last time the comparison to
the Multiverse story so if I understand
what you're saying which I think I
mostly do I can kind of conditionalize
on here I am here's the Big Bang here's
what I observe and then I use your
theory to reconstruct the past and the
future of the universe
yeah could I have
conditionalized on completely different
kinds of people and completely different
laws of physics and things like that and
told a similar story all still within
your framework oh uh
yes yes sure sure you could do a thought
experiment and conditional in fact we do
many of those thought experiments in
theory and conditionalize or start so to
speak from an entirely different
configuration yeah and you would get a
different uh past and future
good all of these past and Futures are
limited just like we discussed as
so good so just if I'm just trying to
get it right so I keep repeating um so
what you're saying is that once I say
who I am the classical world around me
is is finite it's limited because it
sort of dissolves into Quantum
uncertainty if I go too far but I can
think of it as an ensemble of many
different Patchwork classical realities
all of which are there in the wave
function of the universe good this is
his last point I am no longer convinced
of okay good all these different at all
these different classical worlds fit in
one grand wave function that's indeed
the uh the the heart of that top-down
approach taken taken fully
um and the evidence we have for this and
this is a crucial point I think yes the
evidence we have for this is that
they're not all there in one grand wave
function uh when we think uh
holographically about this holographic
holography really sort of yeah it's kind
of interesting it brings in these
observational perspective with in the
theory
but at the same time it then also limits
the range of that wave function that
we've been talking about it limits the
range of different realities that the
wave function encompasses now of course
we're talking really cutting-edge stuff
right but you're actually right is there
a Grand overarching Bay function and
comprising all possible holographic
theories or is there a limitation on the
reach of physical theory that is
contingent on
say a boundary configuration or an
observational configuration
yeah and we don't know yet still work to
be done that remains to be seen yes sure
it's good that not all the questions are
yet answered because that leaves
something for you to say in your next
book
which I predict is going to come out
eventually so Thomas hartog thanks very
much for being on the mindscape podcast
thank you so much Sean lovely
[Music]
no no no no